dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana if I hear I am
sure that every one of us have overheard
conversations at a workplace where
people talked about taking the stairs
instead of the elevator and as a result
getting leaner there was also a running
joke on the internet about Arnold
Classic a famous bodybuilding
competition / Festival where I think
it's fair to say that people tended to
favor the escalator instead of the
stairs so this is it we're going to
settle this here and now do we get lean
from taking the stairs every day
scientists set up a controlled
experiment where over a hundred subjects
client 11 stories of staircases
ascending a total of 27 meters
vertically their oxygen consumption and
heart rate was measured and most
importantly for us the amount of calorie
cost of this undertaking they have found
that all this self flagellation
with ascending eleven stories of
staircases burns a whopping 19 point 7
kilocalories each step is worth
approximately 1/10 of a kilocalorie if
we're ascending descending is worth
approximately half of debt apparently
these bodybuilders know what they are
doing the author's diplomatically noted
stair climbing exercise using a local
public-access staircase met the minimum
requirements for cardio respiratory
benefits and can therefore be considered
a viable exercise for most people and
suitable for promotion of physical
activity which sounds like the
scientific equivalent of basically well
better than nothing so does this mean
that you shouldn't take the stairs at
work if you're looking to get lean
because of that no not a chance
however if you are looking for a
refreshing cardiovascular exercise in
the morning that refreshes your body and
makes you happier start climbing I do it
all the time and I love it we are
exploring so far uncharted territories
and this makes the first episode on
nutrition in the series if you would
like to hear more of this
let me know in the comment section I'd
also be happy to see your paper
recommendations in nutrition as well
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time